an unveiling ceremony more than six
months in the making
high-ranking officials watch as the
Revolutionary guards Aerospace division
displays what Iran says is its first
domestically produced Hypersonic
ballistic missile
named fatah the missile has a range of
1400 kilometers and a speed of more than
15 000 kilometers an hour that's more
than 12 times faster than the speed of
sound it's able to change direction
rapidly and avoid most defense systems
by traveling outside the Earth's
atmosphere president Ibrahim raisy
explained why Iran has developed such a
weapon
it is for deterrence we build this
missile so that our enemies don't even
think about any acts of aggression
against us this unveiling has a message
of security for all in the region not
just Iran people should know the level
of security in the entire region has
increased
despite assurances and Promises from the
president to the contrary this
development is likely to increase
tensions in the region
Iran's ballistic missile program has
been under U.N security Council
sanctions since 2006 a restriction
that's due to be lifted in October as a
result of the 2015 nuclear deal that's
when Iran will be allowed to buy and
sell Advanced missile technology
one of the most important
characteristics of this missile is it
can confront defense systems like that
of enemies of Iran like the U.S and the
Zionist regime since they have very
Advanced defense systems this could have
a significant impact on the weapons the
Americans are selling specially to
Regional countries
program is one of the biggest
it has more than one thousand short and
intermediate ballistic missiles that
carry conventional Warheads but they can
be converted to carrying nuclear ones
that's something officials continue to
maintain they're not seeking while Iran
says it has made significant gains in
its defensive capabilities over the past
two years it's also sought to mend
relations with certain countries in the
Middle East mainly Saudi Arabia and
Egypt as officials stress the
development of this Hypersonic ballistic
missile increases Security in the entire
Middle East it's unclear if Regional
Powers will take the same view
Tehran